[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال الاختيار استهلها بابره
العناو
اوكرانيا تستعيد بلدتين خلال هجومها
المضاد وموسكو تعلن التصدي لزوارق مسيره
ضد اصول البحر الاسود
على وقع عوده الاشتباكات في الخرطوم
ارتفاع نسبه الابلاغ عن المفقودين في
السودان وازمه في هويات الجثث المجهوله
[موسيقى]
محاميه ترامب تؤكد الغاء صفه السريه عن
الوثائق قبل العثور عليها وتصف الاتهامات
بمحاوله سياسيه لمنع موكلها من الترشح
بعدما تاهوا لاربعين يوما في غابات
الامازون تفاصيل مثيره عن قصه نجاه اربعه
اطفال في كولومبيا
[موسيقى]
بلده ثانيه استعادها الجيش الاوكراني في
هجومه المضاد والطريق مفتوحه امام المزيد
لاستعادته شرق اوكرانيا وتحديدا في دنياسك
اما وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فاعلنت التصدي
لهجوم اوكرانيا بسته زوارق مسيره على
سفينه تابعه لاصول البحر الاسود بالقرب من
خطي انابيب يقعان على بعد 300 كم من القرن
كما اعلن التصديها لمئه محاوله اختراق
اوكرانيه عبر المسيرات لمحطه
يسعدني اعلان تحرير قريه بلاغو داتني
بمنطقه دونيتسك وكانت عمليه ناجحه ونحن
الان نشهد النتائج الاولى للهجوم المضاد
[موسيقى]
اليوم في تمام الساعه الواحده والنصف
بتوقيت موسكو قامت القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه بمحاوله فاشله لمهاجمه سفينه
اسطول البحر الاسود الروسيه والتي تقوم
بمهام مراقبه الوضع وضمان الامن على طول
طرق التيار التركي والتيار الازرق وخطوط
انابيب الغاز في الجزء الجنوبي الشرقي من
البحر الاسود
بالتزامن مع هذا التقدم الاوكرانيه قدم
وزير الدفاع الروسيه سرقه لبعض الجنود
الروس بعدما قالت موسكو انهم دمروا اربع
دبابات المانيه صنع من طراز وخمس عربات
مدرعه امريكيه تصنع من طراز برادلي اثناء
التصدي لهجوم الاوكرانيه مضاد واظهر وزير
الدفاع على وظهر طبعا وزير الدفاع على
شاشات التلفزيون الحكومي وهو يمنح وسام
النجم الذهبي لبطل روسيا وهو اعلى وسام
عسكري روسيء للجنود
تشتعل الجبهات وتاتي اقوى الاشارات الرئيس
الاوكراني يتحدث عن تنفيذ عمليات هجوميه
ودفاعيه مضاده وفي موسكو يلقي الهجوم
المضاد بثقله على الكرملين وتتزايد
المخاطر السياسيه على الرئيس الروسي وفق
تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه ووفق
الصحيفه فان موسكو امام جبهه قتال على
الارض واخرى داخليه متوتره
ميدانيا تثير القوه الناريه للاسلحه
الغربيه الاوكرانيه توترا النخب الروسيه
كما تخشى احتماليه قطع جسر كيرش شريان
الحياه بين روسيا وشبه جزيره القرم اضافه
الى انتقال القوات الاوكرانيه من
زابوريجيا نحو ميلتوبل وصولا الى بحر ازوف
سيناريوهات تاتي في وقت تلقي الهجمات على
موسكو بالقرود الحدوديه وما يثار عن
انقسام بين قاده عسكريين روس بظلالها على
الداخل الروسي وضع تقول واشنطن بوست انه
يثير تساؤلات حول قدره بوتين على السيطره
عليه اذ بدت علامات التوتر المتزايد تظهر
حين اعلن عضو مؤثر في البرلمان الروسي
مقرب من المخابرات الروسيه ان روسيا فشلت
حتى الان في جميع اهدافها وبدا لافتا ايضا
ما نقلته الصحيفه عن مصدر مقرب من الدوائر
الدبلوماسيه الروسيه قوله ان هناك اشارات
متواضعه ظهرت على ان موسكو قد تكون مستعده
لتقديم بعض التنازلات يزداد التوتر ايضا
وفق الصحيفه في ظل دعم غربي متواصل لكييف
بالاسلحه كبديل لعضويه النيتو الفوريه ما
يعني تهديدا وجوديا لروسيا وهو ما يبدد ما
كان يعول عليه بوتين في تراجع الدعم
الغربي مع اقتراب الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من خرسان عبر السفير
الدبلوماسيه السابق ومستشار خرسون مستشار
حاكم خرسون سابقا استاذ سابدا من الموضوع
السياسي بما اننا كنا نتحدث عنه التصريح
الاخير لنائبه وزير الدفاع تتحدث بان
تفجير السد هو لمنع الهجوم من الجنوب من
الناحيه الاوكرانيه وايضا لاعاده نشر
القوات الروسيه بتحديدا بمناطق محتله هناك
طبعا هذه تنافي الروايه الروسيه تماما
لانها تسد المنفذ على بعض المعابر على ما
يبدو باننا فقدنا الاتصال
ساعود اليه فور عوده هذا الاتصال وساكمل
بالموضوع الاوكراني الحرب في اوكرانيا
طبعا مشاهدينا كشفت اهميه الاقمار
الصناعيه ساعود
[موسيقى]
الحرب في اوكرانيا كشفت اهميه الاقمار
الصناعيه في الفضاء اكثر من اي وقت مضى
بعدما ارتفعت نسبه استخدام الفضاء ومعدات
المراقبه والانترنت لاغراض عسكريه فهل
يكون الفضاء مسرحا لحرب عالميه ثالثه بدلا
من الارض يحذر هنا موقع نيوزرو الرسل
بعدما كشف بان البنتاغون بدا يجهز قاعده
استخباراتيه لحرب النجوم المستقبليه عبر
طبعا اطلاق مجموعه من الاقمار الصناعيه
تحت اسم ما يعرف بسايلنت باركر الى الفضاء
هذا الصيف بما سيسمح طبعا لهم بمراقبه
تحركات كل من روسيا والصين وهذا الامر
اكدته بلومبرك هنا الاكاديميه الروسيه
للملاحه الفضائيه اعتبرت بان اطلاق مجموعه
ما يعرف بسايلنت باركور اي المرحله
التاليه في عسكره الفضاء يعتبر مرحله
تاليه في هذه العسكره بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده لان البنتاغون قلق من الصين نظرا
لامتلاكها اسلحه مصممه للتدبير الاقمار
الصناعيه وعلى وجه الخصوص الجهاز الصيني
الذي اطلق عام 2021 ونجح طبعا لاحقا في
رفع قمر صناعي صيني الى مدار اعلى سيشكل
مشاهدينا ما يعرف
الصيني ووجود وجود طبعا بالفضاء خطرا على
الاقمار الصناعيه الامريكيه ثابته ويعرض
هذه الاقمار للتدمير وفق ما قالته هنا
قياده الفضاء الامريكيه اما روسيا
فستستطيع هي الاخرى اسقاط او تدمير
الاقمار الصناعيه في حاله حدوث تصادم او
في حاله توجيه مقذوفات حركيه صغيره الحجم
نحو هذه النجوم كما ان موسكو قادره على
اسقاط الاقمار الصناعيه في مدارات منخفضه
بواسطه طائرات مقاتله على ارتفاعات عاليه
طبعا
[موسيقى]
اعد الى
حاكم خرسون سابقا استاذ هل تسمعني بوضوح
السلام عليكم السلام سابدا بموضوع يعني
موضوع الانساني تحديدا بهذه المنطقه نتحدث
عن اكثر من 80 قريه
ويعني مناطق هناك غمرت بالكامل هل حركه
النزوح كيف يمكن وصفه بهذا التوقيت المياه
الكهرباء وطبعا يعني المعونه الاساسيه
للسكان هناك
سؤالك بصراحه ان
تفجير هذا الصاد هذا الكارثه لمحافظه
اخرسون وايضا لمحافظه نيبرو وخاصه لمدينه
لان بصراحه عدد كبير من المصانع وكمان
المنشات
لانتاج الصلب ولا حديث كان معتمده من هذا
المياه من مياح خذ
الان في هذا المنطقه لمنطقه من المياه
وكمان من مياه صفاقه لمساريا وكمان لسوكان
عدد السكان في هذا المنطقه حوالي مليون
نسمه يعني من المعروف بان توقفوا بعض
هذا الكارثه لهذا المنطقه هذا الضرر
لاقتصاد اوكراني شيء في محافظه ميبرو
وكمان اكيد في محافظه
على ما يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مجددا
شكرا لك على هذه المعطيات
[موسيقى]
الى السودان وما ان كادت هدنه الاربع
والعشرين ساعه تنتهي حتى عادت اصوات
الرصاص والقذائف الى ما كانت عليه فقد
تجددت الاشتباكات العنيفه بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع في العاصمه
الخرطوم وتمحورت بحسب مراسل العربيه في
وسط وغرب الخرطوم وفي ام درمان مشيرا الى
استخدام اسلحه ثقيله وخفيفه خلال
الاشتباكات في محيط جسر الحلفايه في مدينه
بحري شماليه الخرطوم حيث توالت الانباء
حول سيطره الجيش عليه هذا واكد مراسل
العربيه سماعدوي مدافع ثقيله وتصاعد السنه
الدخان وتحليق للطيران الحربي منذ ساعات
الصباح مؤكدا ان طيران الجيش قصف تمركزات
لقوات الدعم السريع من الخرطوم وام درمان
المتحدثه الاقليميه بسم الله الاحمر كانت
قد ذكرت ان فرق الحمايه تابعه للجنه في
السودان تستقبل الاتصالات دائما للابلاغ
عن حالات فقدان لافراد من العائلات
السودانيه منذ بدء الصراع قبل حوالي
الشهرين وبحسب المتحدثه لم تتوقف البلاغات
حتى الان مع مرور كل يوم مع استمرار
عمليات البحث عن المفقودين المبلغ عنهم
وشددت ايضا على ان عمليات التقصي دونها
عوائق عديده ابرزها الاقتتال المستمر وشرح
الامكانيات والموارد الطبيه حيث تعيق
عمليات التعرف على الجثامين او انتشالها
التسع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
نتنياهو يشدد على عدم التزام اسرائيل
بالاتفاق النووي بين ايران و واشنطن
ويتحدث عن توجيه ضربه محتمله لطهران
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى مصر حيث انتشلت
السلطات المصريه المركب الذي احترق قباله
ساحل البحر الاحمر بعدما قالت ان ثلاثه
مواطنين بريطانيين فقدوا بعدما اشتعلت
النيران في قارب غطس كانوا على متنه قباله
الساحل على البحر الاحمر كما قالت محافظه
البحر الاحمر ان اكثر من 10 من افراد
الطاقم طاقم واثنى عشر سائحا بريطانيا تم
انقاذهم عندما اشتعلت النيران في المركب
قباله مدينه مدينه هناك
تنضم الينا من الغردقه ندى حجازي مراسله
العربيه ندى يعني مل جديد بهذا الملف
خصوصا بان موضوع يعني اشتعال القارب اثار
الذعر لدى السياح هناك التحقيقات الى ماذا
وصلت وكل التفاصيل معك تفضل
اهلا بك المركبه الان بصدد اخماد النيران
وتبريدها لفحص السبب الرئيسي او الحقيقي
اللي اشتعالها ولكن وفق المؤشرات المبدئيه
اشتعال كان بسبب ماسك كهربائي في غرفه
المحركات
والان يتم فحصها مره اخرى
وفحص المركب وتفقد اذا كانت جسامين
التلات سائحين المفقودين بداخلها واذا لم
يجدوها بداخل المركب فستتوجه الفرق
والتواقم المختصه الى اعماق البحر لتفقدها
يعني لان وقتها سيكون من المؤكد انهم قد
غرقوا في الاعماق اما عن تفاصيل تفاصيل
المركب
واشتعالها والرحله نفسها فالرحله كانت
المفروض من يوم سته اليوم 11 كانت المفروض
متوجهه من المارينا الجديده
بمرسى علم الى مارينا بورت غارب رحله
سياحيه
المركب على متنه 15 سائح بريطاني عشر عشر
اشخاص طاقم المركب واثنين مرشدين سياحيين
تم انقاذ الجميع فقط ثلاثه مفقودين والذي
تم انقاذهم هم بحاله جيده الان موجودين
بمركز سياحي قريب من نقطه انقاذهم
وهي يعني الموضوع كله اخذ اخذ بعض الوقت
لان كمان المركب
الرياح والامواج دفعتها بعيدا عن مكان
الحادث تقريبا 20 كم داخل هذا جعل
انتشالها ياخذ وقتا من يتولى الرقابه على
يعني جهوزيه هذه القوارب لكي تكون مؤهله
لنقل سواح ومن يدقق اذا ما كانت معايير
السلامه فعلا متابعه داخل هذه القوارب
بالطبع جميع المراكب الموجوده في في
البحار يتم فحصها بشكل دوري وقبل ان تاخذ
تصاريح
يعني
لتبدا رحلتها يجب فحصها جيدا ويجب ان تمر
على اكثر من جهه ولكن موضوع الماسه
الكهربائي هي هو حادث فردي يعني
لا يعيب المركب او
وليس وليس شيئا
يعني
اي ملك معرضه لهذا النوع من الحوادث
شكرا لك ندى حجازي مراسله العربيه حدثنا
من الغردقه
[موسيقى]
شدد الاجتماع الوزاري لدول مجلس التعاون
الخليجيه على اهميه التزام ايران بعدم
تجاوز نسبه تخصيب اليورانيوم للاستخدامات
السلميه وضروره التعاون الكامل مع وكاله
الطاقه الذريه كما اكد المجلس في البيان
له على ضروره مشاركه دول الخليج في جميع
المفاوضات بخصوص برنامج ايران النووي وان
تشمل المباحثات كافه القضايا والشواغل
الامنيه لدول مجلس وشدد كذلك على ضروره
الحفاظ على الامن البحري والممرات المائيه
في المنطقه والتصدي لكل ما يهدد خطوط
الملاحه البحريه والتجاره الدوليه
والمنشات النفطيه في دول المجلس هذا
وادادا المجلس اقتحام مقار بعثات
دبلوماسيه لدول مجلس في السودان مؤكدا
ضروره احترام الاتفاقيات الدوليه والاعراف
الدبلوماسيه
هذا واكد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو بانه ابلغ وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن ان احياء الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران ليس كفيلا بوقف البرنامج
النووي الايراني وان اي تسويه يجري التوصل
اليها مع طهران لن تكون ملزمه لبلاده هذا
واكد نتنياهو لبلينكن انه سواء مع الاتفاق
النووي الايراني او من دونه فان بلاده
ستواصل القيام بكل ما يلزم في سبيل الدفاع
عن نفسها
يوم الخميس الماضي تحدثت مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه واكدت على موقفنا الثابت العوده
الى الاتفاق النووي مع ايران لن توقف
برنامج طيران النوويه بل ستسمح لايران فقط
بتوجيه الاموال بمبالغ كبيره الى اذرعها
في المنطقه وحول حدود اسرائيل شددت على ان
اي اتفاق مع ايران لن يلزم اسرائيل مع او
بدون اتفاق سنواصل القيام بكل ما هو ضروري
لحمايه اراضينا
الى ذلك قال المرشد الايراني للاعلى علي
بان الغرب لن يتمكن من منع ايران من تطوير
اسلحه اذا ارادت ذلك واضاف بان بلاده
ستستمر في العمل والتعاون مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بشرط احترام القطاع
النووي الايراني
يجب عدم المساس بالبنيه التحتيه لصناعه
النوويه خلال هذه السنوات قام المديرون
والمسؤولون والناشطون في هذه الصناعه
باعمال مهمه وانشاوا بنيه تحتيه كبيره قد
ترغبون في عقد اتفاقيات في بعض المجالات
النوويه لا توجد مشكله اتفقوا لكن لا
ينبغي المساس بالبنت تحتيه ولا ينبغي ان
تتضرر يجب احترامها فهذه هي نتائج جهود
الاخرين
اسرائيل تخطط لحبل مع ايران من دوله لدوله
هذه المره عبره تنفيذ خطتين الاولى بضربه
موجهه الى برنامج ايراد النووي والثانيه
عبر حرب مباشره مع الحرس الثوري الايراني
في التفاصيل انشات اسرائيل وحده جديده في
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاسرائيليه وهي
وحده معروفه باسم 54 وهذا الفرع الحديث لم
يحصل حتى الساعه على اسم رسم البعض ويتشكل
مشاهدينا من ثلاثين فردا بين ضباط وجنود
مهمه هؤلاء اعداد بنك الاهداف في ايران
لشن حرب محتمله ودراسه ومتابعه قوات الحرس
الثوري الايراني اسرائيل اقدمت ايضا على
هذه الخطه بعدما وصلت لنتيجه مفاد هذه
النتيجه بان اي مواجهه مستقبليه مع ايران
ستكون في الاغلب مواجهه في على اكثر من
جبهه والحرب قد تكون حرب استنزاف تستمر
لايام طويله
بالبنى التحتيه طبعا للطرفين لكن فشل
المحادثات حول الايراني حول النووي
الايراني والتطورات المتسارعه في ذات
البرنامج والانتقال بالحديث عن قرب ايران
من امتلاكها قنبله نوويه من سنوات الى
اسابيع قليله او ربما ايام هذا الامر
بالذات سرع في خطه اسرائيل الحربيه
المباشره مع ايران التي تمتلك اسلحه
متطوره مثل طبعا المسيرات وصواريخ كروز
وصواريخ فرض صوتيه التي يصل مداها الى عمق
تل ابيب
[موسيقى]
من طهران ينضم الينا الدكتور محمد صالح
صديقان مدير المركز العربي للدراسات
الايرانيه دكتور تهديدات نتنياهو يعني بعد
كل السياسات الماضيه سياسه الاغتيالات
سياسه الحرب بين الحروب بين
الحرب الكبرى وايضا سياسه الرد على
الاستراتيجي كلها لم تمنع ايران من ان كان
من دوره بالمنطقه وان كان من موضوع
امتلاكها لاسلحه متطوره اليوم ماذا يمكن
ان يفعل نتنياهو
لتكون تهديداته فعلا
تؤتي الى نتيجه مع الجانب الايراني
مساء الخير لك المشاهدين ان يعتقد بان
نتنياهو يعاني من ازمه حقيقيه في داخل
اسرائيل وبالتالي هناك اضطرابات كثيره
هناك معارضه كثيره ايضا وهناك عجز في
مواجهه التهديدات التي تواجه الكيان
الاسرائيلي في الداخل وبالتالي هو يريد ان
يعبر بهذه
المشاكل الداخليه التي يعاني منها وتعاني
منها حكومته يحاول ان ان
يتجاوز ذلك الى
السير نحو الامام وبالتالي يريد تسويق هذه
المشاكل الى الخارج وهو الان هو امام ازمه
جديده من خلال
تمثيل صفقه التبادل المعتقلين بين ايران
والدول الغربيه من خلال
المباحثات الجيده والايجابيه التي جرت بين
ايران والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
لتسويه المشاكل المعلقه بين طهران
والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه اضافه الى
عن بعض من الوداع الايرانيه المحتجزه مثل
هذه الامور اني اعتقد بان نتنياهو يعتقد
بان اي اتفاق مع طهران سواء كان من قبل
الولايات المتحده او الاوروبيين يؤثر على
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي وبذلك هو يريد ان
ان يسوق او يريد ان يعبر هذه المشاكل
الداخليه التي يعاني منها من اجل مواجهه
ايران
الموازات يعني التفاهمات التي
حاكتها ايران مع الجانب الغربي بالاشهر
الماضيه اليوم من المعلوم بان اوراق الضغط
التي كان يستعملها نتنياهو الحكومات
السابقه ان كان داخل الكونجرس الامريكي
تراجعت ان كان من خلال حشد الدعم دعم
الدول الاوروبيه ايضا تراجعت لان الدول
الاوروبيه اليوم تعتقد بان اللحمه
الاوروبيه الامريكيه اذا ما يعني اضيعت
بموضوع الحرب بالشرق الاوسط ممكن ان تضيع
البوصله مع تحديدا روسيا هذين العاملين
الذين يعني غير موجودين اليوم معنا
ثانياهم كيف يمكن ايضا ان يؤثران على
موقفه وعلى يعني تحويل تهديده الى شيء جدي
ان يعتقد بان هناك معادلات جديده في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط سواء كان تلك التي تخص
الجانب الايراني او تلك التي تخص الكيان
الاسرائيلي انا اعتقد بان ايران الان
لديها من الاوراق ما يمكن ان تعتمد عليها
في اي مفاوضات يمكن ان تكون مع الوكاله
الدوليه مع الاوروبيين مع الجانب الامريكي
وبالتالي هناك الكثير من الاوراق القويه
التي تستخدمها طهران هناك تقدم كبير جدا
في المنظومه الصاروخيه الايرانيه هناك
بالبرنامج الايراني هناك بالبرامج النووي
الايراني هناك تقدم كبير ايضا سواء كان
على نسبه التخصيب او على مستوى نوعيه
البرنامج
والامكانيات الهائل التي تمتلكها ايران
اضافه الى ذلك بان هناك اقتناع لدى
الاداره الامريكيه وتحديدا عند ويليام
رئيس وك المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
الذي يعتقد بان البرنامج الاتفاق النووي
الموقع في عام 2015 هو افضل اتفاق يمكن ان
يحدد الطموح الايراني في المجال النووي
وبالتالي الكل يعلم بان نسبه التخصيب التي
وردت في الاتفاق النووي الواقع عام 2015
هي نسبه
3.67 فيما الان ايران تخصب 60% وبالتالي
يعني اعتقد بان هذه العتبه الجديده
القريبه من الاسلحه النوويه
ويليامبرز تحديدا عندما يشير الى ويليام
بيرث لانه هناك قناعه كامله عن ويليامبرز
بان ان ان الاتفاق النووي هو الاتفاق
الافضل الذي يربط ايران مع الدول الغربيه
هو النقطه الثانيه بان هذا الاتفاق صدر
بحقه قرار اممي صادر من مجلس الامن الدول
المرقم 22 31
اضافه الى انه يستطيع ان
يحقق الكثير من الانجازات للدول الغربيه
لكن هو يعتقد ايضا بان هناك خطا كبير وقعت
فيه الولايات المتحده عندما انسحب الرئيس
ترامب من هذا الاتفاق شكرا لك محمد صالح
صدقان مدير المركز العربي للدراسات
الايرانيه على وجودك معنا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من القدس عبر زوم
يوني بنمح مناحيم المحلل السياسي استاذ
يعني اليوم تهديدات نتنياهو كما سمعت مع
ضيفي دون الكثير من العواقب والعوائق لكي
تصبح حقيقه الجانب الامريكي بكل التسريبات
الاخيره وعاد الجانب الاسرائيلي ببعض
الضمانات في حال تم توقيع الاتفاق النووي
مع ايران هذه الضمانات على ماذا تنص
ولماذا لم تقنع الجانب الاسرائيلي حتى
الساعه
لان هذه الضمانات لا تشمل الخيال العسكري
وهذا هو اهم شيء لانه
ليس هناك اي انسان يصدق كل الروايات
الايرانيه وهذا ليس السير بان ايران تسعى
الى انتاج القنبله النوويه وكل التصريحات
الايرانيه بانه لا تريد سلاح نووي هي
التضليل
وبنفس الوقت لن تقوم بالجهد كبير للتقدم
باتجاه القنبله النوويه ولذلك
التهديد الوحيد
وتهديد الخيار العسكري وضمانات الامريكيه
لا
تشمل امكانيات الخيال العسكري لان الرئيس
بايدن يريد الحل الدبلوماسي
ويريد ان يظهر كان لدي انجاز في المعهد
الانتخابيه حتى حتى بموضوع الخيار عسكري
مع نتنياهو هنا اعود الى موضوع بان الخطاب
هو خطاب شعبي للداخل اكثر مما هو خطاب
حقيقي بالتهديد للخارج بالفتره الماضيه
كان هناك تسريبات بان الجانب الامريكي
اعطى نوع من الضوء الاخضر لنتنياهو لانجاز
الضربه التي يتحدث عنها دائما الا انه
تردد لانه يعلم اي ضربه عسكريه على ايران
تعني فتح شبهات متعدده اتحدثون عن الجبهه
الشماليه الاسرائيلي وهو طبعا يعني بجبهه
واحده مع الجانب الفلسطيني وكان هناك ازمه
كبيره في الداخل هل اليوم الجزء الاكبر من
التهديد هو للاستهلاك الداخلي اكثر مما هو
عزم لضرب ايران عسكريه
لا هذا لم يكن هناك اي ضوء اخضر من
الولايات المتحده في الماضي
هذا ليس صحيح كل الاخبار هاي التي تغددت
هي ليس صحيحه دائما كان هناك موقف
الولايات المتحده بايجاد الحله الدبلوماسي
وليس الحل العسكري
ويخطي من يفكر بانى
اقوال نتنياهو تصريحات هي الاستهلاك
المحلي
التصريحاته هي
مواجهه للاداره الامريكيه لكي يفهم الرئيس
بايدن اذا فعلا سيكون هناك
اتفاق جديد
بين الولايات المتحده وبين الدول العظمى
لايران وهذا الاتفاق هو ليس لصالح اسرائيل
ويعطي الحساب امن المواطنين في اسرائيل
فستكون هناك ضربه اسرائيليه للمفاعل
النوويه الايرانيه
اذا شكرا لك استاذ يونس المحلل السياسي
حدثتنا من القدس
[موسيقى]
افاد رئيس هيئه الدفاع عن الرئيس العراقي
الاسبق صدام حسين الدكتور خليل الدليمي
خلال احدى حلقات برنامج الذاكره السياسيه
بان الحبل الذي نفذ به اعدام صدام حسين
كان مكون من 39 عقد وهو عدد الصواريخ التي
اطلقتها بغداد ضد تل ابيب بنى حرب الخليج
هل صحيح انه عدد عقد الحبل حبل المشنقه
كان على عدد صواريخ التي ضربها صدام حسين
على اسرائيل هذا ما نقل من داخل قاعه
المحكمه قاعه الادم
39 39 نقطه
على عدد الصواريخ التي قصف بها اسرائيل
هل مات شنقا فعلا
كانت كانت عمليه اعدام عمليه غوائيه
يعني انت تؤكد لنا الشكوك حول
موته شنقا نعم عمليه غوغائيه عمليه اداما
من اطلاق الشعراء الى التهديد الى اخر
مرحله
هو الذي رفض فعلا وضع الكيس نعم
عندما تقول غوغائيه يعني تتجاوز الشنق
هكذا تفسر
ماذا كان دور الضباط الايرانيين
ايثار رساله انه احنا اللي عدمناك فقط
في معلومات تقول انه كان عندهم اهداف اخرى
متعلقه بالتاكد من هويه من يقومون باعدامه
ربما
يعني اخذوا مثلا
اشياء معينه من جسده للفحوص
لا اعتقد
ماذا حصل بالجثمان بعد الوفاه
نقل الى بيت نور المالكي تشفين
في يوم زواج
نجله احمد
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من بغداد واثق
الجابري الباحث السياسي استاذ واثق يعني
سابدا من نقطه وجود ضباط ايرانيين خلال
المحاكمه هذه الروايه الى اي مدى هي دقيقه
وايضا موضوع الحبل يعني هناك
روايتين بروايه واحده حبل فيه عدد
الصواريخ التي اطلقت على تل ابيب ووجود
ايضا ضباط ايرانيين كيف تعلق على هذا
التصريح
نعم شكرا جزيلا لكم وتحي لكم مشاهديكم
الكرام وبطبيعه الحال هذا الكلام كله نسج
من الخيال واوهام بحقيقه يعني صدام اعدم
بابسط الادوات التي كان يمارسها لاعدام
العراقيين لم يعدم باحواض التيزاب ولا
بالقتل المباشر ولا بالمحاكمات الشكليه
ولا بدفن المواطنين احياء اعدم من محكمه
عراقيه شكلت بعد بعد سقوط النظام المحكمه
كانت علنيه وجود وجود محامين محامين
عراقيين وغير عراقيين وبالتالي كانت
المحاكمه والاعدام بشكل علني امام
العراقيين وامام الملا وكل العالم كان
يطلع على تفاصيل المحاكمه لا يوجد
ايرانيين ولا يوجد تدخلات ولا وليس له
علاقه
يمكن حتى ابنه الرئيس الراحل رغد صدام
حسين في مقابله سابقه مع العربيه اكدت
وجود ضباط ايرانيين خلال المحاكمه وخلال
الاعدام
تحديدات خلال هذه الجلسه للتاكد بانه فعلا
تم اعدام صدام حسين وليس شبيه وليس اي احد
اخر
هذا هذا الكلام يريدون ان يصنعون من صدام
بطل قومي وكانما هو بطل حارب لكن النتيجه
صدام كان النهايه هي التي تدلل على حقيقه
يعني ما كان يفعله النظام وما كان نهايه
هذا النظام الذي انتهى الى الى حفره وكيف
واخرج من هذه الحفره
يعني بارتكابه جرائم بدءا من يعني من
تشكيل النظام يعني كان بانقلاب دموي ثم
الانقلاب على جماعته ثم ادخال العراق بعده
لمنطقه الدوله العربيه
بمنطق الدوله حتى ولو ارتكب جرائم عمليه
المحاكمه يجب ان تتم حسب الاصول القانونيه
وحتى الدينيه لانها تراعي هذه النصوص
عندما نتحدث عن اكثر من جانب يقول بان
عمليه الاعدام حصلت بطريقه غوغائيه وكان
فيها العديد يعني من الممارسات التي
تتنافى مع حقوق الانسان مع الدين مع كل
شيء
وبالتالي يعني لا يمكن ان يجذب كل
الاصدقاء بهذا الموضوع
لا هو هو حكم اولا على قضيه واحده من بين
مئات الاف القضايا شيء ثاني بشكل علني
وكان له محامين واحضر الشهود واصحاب الحق
الشخصي بهذه القضيه بالتالي يعني مساله
يعني هم مساله انه رددت اصوات يعني اثناء
المحاكمه في العراقيين يعني كانوا لو كان
صداما في الشارع لقد قطعوه وهذه بنهايه كل
كل حاكم ظالم ديكتاتور ممكن شاهدنا يعني
حتى في الدول العربيه شاهدنا يعني الحاكم
الديكتاتور كيف ينتقم منه شعبه وبالتالي
هذه الخطابات لم تؤثر على سير محاكمه
المحاكمه كانت بشكل علني والاعدام كان
بشكل علني وعدي بشكل اصولي من محكمه مدنيه
لم يحكم
كالمحاكمات التي كانت ينفذها بدون او بدون
محاكمات ودون محامي ودون وجود المدعي
العامه هنا في محكمته كان المدعي العام
وموجود
موجود المحامين وموجود الشهود وموجود
القضاه وبشكل علني واعطي المجال لان يدافع
عن نفسه وان يبرر يعني لا اعتقد يعني
القضيه هي بهذا الشكل وهذه نتيجه حتميه
نعم نعم المحاكمه العادله التي تتحدث عنها
وبشكل القانوني هل تسمح بان يتم اخذ جثه
صدام حسين الى عرس ابن نوري المالكي والى
فرحه طبعا
والتنكيل بها هناك هل هل هذا يتناسب مع
الاعراف القانونيه او مع الدين او مع اي
شيء
هذه ليس حقيقه يعني مثل ما ادعى المحامي
ان العدد
يعني مقاطع الحبل الذي اعدم به بعدد
الصواريخ وانه يعني مثل به بهذا الشكل هذا
ادعاء غير صحيح والا صدام يعني حتى في
قبره نبش من اقاربه ومن الناس الذين كانوا
ينتقبون رغم انه دفن في منطقه
بشكل طبيعي
وفق الاصول والقوانين وحتى الشرائع رعيت
فيها الشرائع الاسلاميه بطريقه الدفن
وبشكل صحيح لم يكون هنالك نوع من التشفي
والانتقام ولا ولم يكن للحكومه تدخل
بطبيعه القضاء العراق الذي
اطاله حتى فتره المحاكمه والا مجرد النظر
يمكن ان يعطي لكل هذه المحاكمه على كل حال
يعني السياسه هي اساس هذه المحاكمه شكرا
لك من بغداد واثق الجابر البحث السياسي
حدثت نا عن هذه القضيه
[موسيقى]
اعلن بيان لخليه الاعلام الامنيه في
العراق مقتل ضابطين اثنين واصابه ثلاثه
جنود بهجوم في محافظه كركوك وذكر البيان
ان الضابطين احدهما برتبه مقدم والاخر
برتبه ملازم اول
اعلنت السلطات التي تقودها قوات قصت في
شمال شرقي سوريا ان الفي اجنبي من مقاتل
تنظيم داعش المحتجزين في سجون في المنطقه
سيحاكمون بعدما رفضت بلدانهم الاصليه
استعادتهم قصد جددت مطالبتها انشاء محكمه
دوليه لمحاكمه هؤلاء المقاتلين من حوالي
60 جنسيه كما دعت الامم المتحده وجماعات
حقوق الانسان الدوليه الى المساعده في
تسهيل المحاكمات هذا وتحتجز قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه المدعومه من الولايات المتحده
والتي يقودها الاكراد اكثر من عشره الاف
من مقاتل داعش الاسرى في حوالي 20 مركز
احتجاز
تتابعنا في التاسع ولكن بعد قليل
لوقف الهجره نحوها اوروبا تقدم 100 مليون
يورو لتونس وسعيد يقول لن نكون حراسا
للحدود
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعتبرت محاميه الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامبو حلفاء له
ان الاحتفاظ بمستندات بعد مغادرته البيت
الابيض بصفتها تذكرات شخصيه او وثائق رفعت
عنها السريه كانت ضمن حقوقها مستنكرين
الملاحقات السياسيه التي يتعرض لها بدورها
قال رئيس لجنه الشؤون القضائيه بمجلس
النواب الجمهوري لشبكه سي ان ان قدره
الرئيس على التصنيف والتحكم في الوصول الى
معلومات الامن القومي مستمده من الدستور
واضاف بان ترامب رفع السريه عن عاد هذه
المواد ويمكنه وضعها في اي مكان يريده
ويمكنه التعامل معها كما يشاء
اذا ورغم اتهامه بسبعه وثلاثين قضيه
جنائيه لا شيء سيوقف ترامب عن سباق
الرئاسه الى البيت الابيض هكذا اكد الرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق بعدما قال انه بريء وهو
ضحيه مؤامره دبرها خصومه الديمقراطيون
لعرقله وصوله الى البيت الابيض الذي يامل
بالعوده اليه في عام 2024 وهنا يطرح
السؤال او يطرح السؤال نفسه هل يخوض ترامب
السباق من وراء القضبان وهل ستؤثر هذه
الاتهامات على اصوات ناخبيه هنا صحيفه
اعتبرت بانه كلما ازدادت الاتهامات
الموجهه الى ترامب سواء بدت ترامب اكثر
كضحيه مضطهده من قبل مؤسسه انتقاميه
يديرها ديمقراطيون راديكاليون وجمهوريون
بالاسم فقط ويميل هنا مؤيد الى تصديقه حيث
يعتقد ثمانيه من كل عشره بانه ضحيه وفقا
لوصف الصح طبعا هذه النقطه سيستغلها ترامب
جيدا وسيظهر نفسه كمستهدف وبانه يقاتل
ببساله ضد النخبه السياسيه الفاسده وهذا
بدا طبعا واضحا في مؤتمر الصحفي بالامس
عندما شدد ان لائحه الاتهام ضده مزيفه
ويحاكم فقط بسبب محاولته الفوز بولايه
رئاسيه ثانيه ترامب مشاهدينا اوضح في وقت
سابق انه سيجعل المحاكمه جزءا من حملته
الرئاسيه ونجح بذلك منذ لحظه توجيه
الاتهام اليه وتمكنت حملته من جمع اكثر من
اربعه ملايين دولار خلال 24 ساعه وايضا
وسع فيها الفارق مع اقرب منافسيه المتهمين
بالترشح على المهتمين بالترشح على بطاقه
الحزب الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا مشاهدينا من عشره مراسله
العربيه للتسليمان اخر التحديث بلائحه
الاتهام الطويله ضد ترامب ومثوله امام
المحكمه
طبعا نحن بانتظار يوم الثلاثاء المقبل
لمصول الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب امام
المحكمه فيما يعني امام المحكمه
الفيدراليه طبعا
الاتهامات هي نفسها التي يواجهها بمخص
الوثائق التي اكتشفت في مقره فيما لاغو
التصعيد الذي مارسه ترامب في يومين
الماضيين حيال هذه الاتهامات كان كبيرا
وكان له وقع كبير في الشارع ولد مؤيديه
ومناصريه ايضا ولكن الضربه القاضيه التي
حصلت الترامب منذ يومين حتى اليوم هي
تصريحات من اصدقائه وحلفائه السابقين
دعيني اشير الى بلبار الذي شغل منصب وزير
العدل في احدى ادارات ترامب اعتبر بالبار
بانه اذا نصح منصف هذه الاتهامات
ترامب يعتبر منتهيا تماما لانه الان بحسب
بالبار هناك اتهامات بالتجسس قضيه كبيره
جدا بالنسبه للرئيس ترامب ولكن لا يجب ان
نذهب انه هذا الموضوع لا يمكن ان يمنعه من
الترشح للانتخابات المقبله ليال لعده
اعتبارات وايضا لانه هناك ايضا قضايا اخرى
بانتظار الرئيس ترامب ليتم محاكمته عليها
هذه الاتهامات بموازاه بدء ترامب حملته
الانتخابيه وكل يعني الاحاديث عن انها
ستصب لصالح ترامب ان كان داخل الحزب وان
كان مع جمهور الحزب ما هي اخر التحديثات
بها هاتين النقطتين تحديدا
في هذه كل الاتهامات التي يتهم بها ترامب
يستغلها لصالحه وهو اعلن ذلك وهو يمارسها
تماما ان كان لدى قوله لقعدته الشعبيه
بانه مظلوم انظروا هناك العديد من الرؤساء
والمسؤولين الديمقراطيين تحديدا اخذوا مثل
هذه الوثائق تماما كما فعلت انا ولكنه لا
يتم محاسبتهم وذهب بالقول بانه حتى هلري
كلينتن نفسها اتخذت خطوات تصعيديه اكثر هي
في مركزها في وزاره الخارجيه اخذت
وثائق اكثر اهميه واحتفظت بها ولكن لم
يحاسبها احد لانها ديمقراطيه وهذا ما اثار
غضب الجمهوريين والقاعده الشعبيه من بعض
السياسيين الجمهوريين يدافعون عن ترامبس
مثل الانستقرام التي اعتبر بانه ما يحصل
ترامب امر السياسي بحث ولا وليس هناك اي
شك من ذلك حتى
منافسيه على الرئاسه في الحزب الجمهوري ان
كان مايك بانتس او حتى رونديز لم يواجهوا
التحم للترامب بل اعتبروا انه ما يحصل هو
تهم سياسيه فقط لا غير شكرا
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الدفاع التايواني بانها ارسلت
مقاتلات جويه بعدما عبرت عشر طائرات حربيه
صينيه من طرازات مختلفه لخط الوسط
الافتراضي لمضيق الجزيره واضافت الوزاره
التايوانيه ايضا بان اربع سفن حربيه صينيه
قامت بدوريات قتاليه واكدت بانها ارسلت
طائرات مقاتله ونشرت سفونان وانظمه صواريخ
بريه لمراقبه الوضع مكرره صياغه تستخدمها
عاده عندما تشرح طريقه ردها على الانشطه
العسكريه السريعه وهذه هي المره الثانيه
في اقل من اسبوع التي تعلن فيها تايوان
رصد انشطه عسكريه لبكين بعدما حلقت 37
طائره عسكريه صينيه الخميس الماضي في نطاق
منطقه الدفاع الجوي للجزيره
[موسيقى]
بحث الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد مع ثلاثه من
قاده الاتحاد الاوروبي ملفات عده ابرز هذه
الملفات مكافحه الهجره غير النظاميه حيث
اعلن عن تخصيص 100 مليون يورو لتونس من
اجل احتواء تدفق المهاجرين نحو اوروبا
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
مستعد لتقديم مساعدات ماليه لتونس تقدر
بنحو 900 مليون يورو الى جانب تقديم 150
مليون يورو اضافيه في مواجهه ازمتها
الحاليه
اندرويد
نحن مستعدون لتقديم مساعدات ماليه لتونس
تبلغ نحو 900 مليون يورو بالاضافه الى
تقديم 150 مليون يورو اضافيه لدعم تونس
بازمتها الحاليه الاتحاد الاوروبي يعتبر
الشريك التجاريه الاكبر لتونس ونحن نسمح
لزياده هذه الشراكه التجاريه وتقويتها
لزياده فرص الوظائف في البلاد
يفترشون الارض ويلتحفون السماء هنا صفاقس
التونسيه حيث لا حيلت للمهاجرين غير
النظاميين سوى الانتظار ريثما تحين ساعه
النجده من هذه القوارب تبدا رحله تتضاءل
فيها فرص الحياه الوجهه ايطاليا لكن
العبور اليها قد ينذر بموت قادم ما زالت
تبكيه الامهات على الشواطئ
تتقاذفهم الامواج والبلدان فحتى قبل
ابحارهم يتناهى الى مسامعهم نباوا التصدي
لقدومهم تونس تلك الدوله التي تشكو ازمه
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه متى يرهقها تدفقهم
مباحثات مشتركه مع زعماء ايطاليا وهولندا
والاتحاد الاوروبي تهدف الى تمهيد الطريق
لخطه انقاذ تونس ومعها كم المهاجرين هذا
اكثر من عشره الاف من الفرين والاعداد غير
دقيقه هكذا ترجح بيانات الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد بعد زياره مفاجئه لصفاقس التي
تعج بهم توسط فيها المهاجرين وبعد ان
استمع لبعض شكواهم اوضح ان بلاده ليست
بوابه حدوديه لاوروبا ولا يمكن ايضا ان
نقوم بالدور الذي
يفسح عنه البعض ويخفيه البعض الاخر بان
نكون حراسا
لدولهم لا الحل لا يمكن ان يكون الا
انسانيا وجمعيا بناء على مقاييس انسانيه
ولكن في ظل القانون
مشتركه لحل واحده من اطول الازمه السياسيه
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي وذلك بعد التوصل
لخطه مبدئيه لتقاسم مسؤوليتهم لكن قد تكون
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني
التي زارت تونس مرتين في اسبوع الطرف
الاشد في منعهم من ان تطا اقدامهم بلادها
اسراء الصغير العربيه
[موسيقى]
تواصلوا قوافل الحجاج وفدها الى مكه
والمدينه في طريقها الى المشاعر المقدسه
استعدادا لاداء مناسك حج هذا العام
استعدادات كبيره من قبل الجهات المعنيه في
السعوديه لتسهيل حركه تناقلهم داخل
المشاعر ووسطى توقعات بتدفق ملايين الحجاج
الى المشاعر المقدسه خلال ايام المقبله
عملت الجهات المختصه على تجهيز 160 الف
مخيم لاستقبال الحجاج في مشعري عرفات
وايضا منا حيث تم تزويد هذه المخيمات
بكافه الخدمات التي يتطلبها الحجاج
[موسيقى]
كتبت الحياه من جديد لاربعه اطفال بينهم
رضيع بينما قضوا اربعين يوما من الضياع في
غابات الامازون حادثه ادهشت العالم في
تفاصيلها حيث بقي الاطفال على قيد الحياه
بسبب مهارات وارشادات الاخت الكبرى التي
لا يتجاوز عمرها 13 عاما
اختفوا وهنا سجلت احداث مثيره بل اكثر
اطفال في دهاليز الامازون لم يعرف لهم اثر
لاربعين يوما
حوى الطائرهم الى هنا بهذا الشكل توفي
الجميع ليبدا سيناريو لحكايه نجاه لثلاثه
اطفال ورضيع
لا تتجاوز اعمارهم الثلاثه عشر عاما كيف
عاشت اجسادهم في غابات هي الاخطر اجابت
ليسلي الاخت الكبرى بعد انقاذهم معجزه
البقاء تعود لدقيق الكسافه ومهارات تمييز
بين النباتات اتقنتها الطفله من جدتها
عمليه التفتيش تعقدت خيوطها في كولومبو
لاسابيع تفككتت بفضل ليسلي ابنه الثلاثه
عشر عاما تركت اثارا في اماكن مختلفه
لترشد المنقذين اليها
المجتمع المحلي والقوات العسكريه كانوا
يبحثون معا ووجدنا الاطفال بعد اربعين
يوما لكن هم وحدهم من سهل لنا الطريق
وتمكنوا من ان يكونوا قدوه للبقاء حادثه
ستسجل في التاريخ
وصلوا محملين بتاريخ من الصمود كما عبر
المجتمع الكولومبي وايضا بحكايه نجاح
سيتسابق عليها منتج الافلام لسرد قصه
باحداث اكثر واقعيه واثاره قصه لابد ان
تنتهي بتصفيق جماهيري حار كما الواقع ايضا
غذاء سالم العربيه
الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان يصبح قاتلا
متوحشا ويقضي على البشر تحذيرات عديده تدق
ناقوس الخطر قبل فوات الاوان وفق تقرير
صحيفه انديبندن التي كشفت وكشف فيهم بان
مسؤولين بريطانيين طالبوا بضروره تنظيم
منتجي ومنتجي ومطوري الذكاء الاصطناعي على
نطاق عالمي وخلق انظمه قويه جدا تمكن
الجميع من السيطره على هذه التقنيه
الجديده اما المدير التنفيذي للشركه فعاد
وكرر موقفه السابق بانه خائف من الذكاء
الاصطناعي التوليدي الذي ساهم بتطويره قبل
ايام اعلن مستشار رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشيسوناك لشؤونه التكنولوجيا بان الذكاء
الاصطناعي يمكن ان يصبح قويا بما يكفي
لقتل العديد من البشر في غضون عامين فقط
[موسيقى]
الى جزر جزر هاواي في الولايات المتحده
حيث يستمر بركان بالثوران بينما تحيط به
انهار وبحيرات من الحمم البركانيه
المنصهره فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
في الختام مشاهدينا تذكير بابرز العناوين
اوكرانيا تستعد او تستعيد بلدتين خلال
هجومها المضاد وموسكت تعلن التصدي لزوارق
مسيره ضد اسطول البحر الاسود
على وقع عوده الاشتباكات في الخرطوم
ارتفاع نسبه الابلاغ عن المفقودين في
السودان وازمه في هويات الجثث المجهوله
محاميه تراب تؤكد الغاء صفه السريه عن
الوثائق قبل العثور عليها وتصف الاتهامات
بمحاوله سياسيه لمنع موكلها من الترشح
بعدما تاهوا لاربعين يوما في غابات
الامازون تفاصيل مثيره عن قصه نجاه اربعه
اطفال في كولومبيا
مشاهدينا ان هنا اتي الى ختام التاسع شكرا
لحسن المتابعه والى اللقاء والان الى 360
مع الزملاء راويه وطاهر راويه وطاهر مساء
الخير وماذا لديكم اهلا بك ليال مساء
الخير ومساء الخير لك طاهر طبعا ليال
سنكون مع المزيد من التفاصيل في المقابله
الخاصه التي اجراها الزميل طاهر ببرنامج
الذاكره السياسيه حول يوم اعدام الرئيس
السابق صدام حسين سنتابع ايضا راويه وليال
المزيد من الصور التي تقول روسيا انها
لمقبره الدبابات الغربيه في اوكرانيا ارجو
ان تكوني معنا الهواء لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات